so we had to because of the lack of
releases this year are like category Wii
U is pretty sparse for our end of the
year awards we left out tons of very
important Wii U games re-releases of
games like Minecraft the minecraft funny
coming to wii u uh Mario & Sonic at the
rio olympic winter gain rheological
Summer Games the a nameless other game
names games that I could name English
all right it doesn't know what a lot all
right so I do we can talk about the few
games that did come out um I do want to
talk about kind of you know like it's
kind of tough not to talk by the
nintendo switch announcement and
nintendo switches impending release i
know in the next coming months we'll get
more news about it but it does make
sense now that the we use the life cycle
is just effectively ending it's coming
to a close and intent of switches on the
horizon finally it's not the nxe more
Pete and I were both limiting that
people going out at the NX yeah i mean
like i called the wii the revolution for
a while and then I finally came around
but hopefully they an actual stick more
in my mind but Justin tell me about this
again this new console like receive the
announcement trailer right here showing
students all the way you a very
confusing trailing trailer followed like
everything you can do with it what not
confusing it makes sense but just the
amount of different ways you could play
this console I do want to touch on that
quick how how's it going to change like
how we play Nintendo games really
ideally how would it based on what we've
seen of it so from the trailer it almost
seems like it's a all-in-one consult
this is both your home console and
something that's going to replace a 3d
yes and I think Nintendo has is come out
and at least talked around that saying
that the 3ds is still going to live on
its own that this doesn't supersede the
3ds as a platform as the handheld system
and that's what investors want to hear
though because it's their best selling
thing they're not going to say we're
gonna kill our best selling thing for a
bit well they're not gonna kill her
best-selling thing for a bit like we
still have 2017 with some good 3ds
titles on the horizon I mean who knows
how much longer it's going to last
beyond that but you have a budget price
system there were rumors that the switch
could come into two hundred dollars
which like that itself would be a game
changer but right now the 3ds is kind of
the budget system it's real
friendly for kids it has a long battery
life and I think it has a lot of
positives that something like just being
more powerful doesn't necessarily make a
handheld system better light look at
vita like despite being an excellent
system with a really great set of games
you can play the entire library of
playstation 1 classics and the games
that you do play on it look one hundred
percent better than 3ds and it was
stomped by the 3ds just because of its
library the library do is help titles
but I think there were a lot of things
that went into it like it when it came
out it was more expensive that 3ds you
were able to manufacture for it faster
and just the people don't want a
handheld experience that's going to be
what you get on console like as much as
I think like playing breadth of the wild
is gonna be really fun I can go out of
the park and do like no I don't want to
go in the park and play breath of the
wild bright breadth of the while is a
game that I'm gonna play in my living
room at home like in the games that I
play on the go when I'm on the bus like
those are different experiences and they
have to be made to be different I have
to be able to close them quickly to be
able to save anywhere I want and be able
to get in and out of that game play
quickly which is a strength of the 3ds
and something I we're talking about the
Wii U but something that the wii u never
quite also found its niche it never
found its thing that separated that that
made it a compelling thing to buy
separately from but the other had Justin
the gamepad was a mistake I think it was
a good idea that both came too late and
wasn't the right thing like the switch
is what I thought I'd like I remember
seeing the wii u's reveal when it when
it first came out and you're like oh my
god they're making a portable tablet
nintendo console and like oh no actually
this is tethered your your living room
you you really can't even go to the
bathroom without losing your connection
and the battery dies in like an hour and
a half so yeah it's just so like the
tech is just so low on that thing and
that's the only reason system costs as
much as it does like it's not a powerful
console it has a bad peripheral that you
have to use and games like Star Fox like
you feel like Nintendo is cramming this
thing down your throat yeah when
everyone is just like please please get
rid of it please don't do this they're
like guess what we don't care in like
the last year of its life cycle they're
still trying to
promote this tech I feel like they you
know that we finally nailed it with like
skyward sword or something and forget
how long into that that was before that
we you but well we saw them arguing with
themselves this year especially with the
we that we saw things like Star Fox
where you're forced to use motion
controls that don't work that that that
is not the best way to play this game
but you also have have games like Donkey
Kong where or other experiences where
that control to the screen does nothing
it's just a blank black screen if you
want to play it portably onto the wii u
screen you could do that but well it was
almost Nintendo admitting like oh yeah
we're gonna be making experiences that
don't require both screens and we know
this ahead of time so I thought but for
all intents purposes the wii u is almost
done like I mean very the wild is still
gonna crown on Wii U so there's
something to look forward to but this
year has been a bit I I would definitely
say abysmal at the beginning of the year
we had smash when we had an update for
smash brothers the last two characters
not the the most important mud the most
interesting but I mean that's the thing
like the most exciting things for the
console were for a game that came out
years ago that's a huge game but if
that's one of the highlights of the year
I think something was up I mean it
doesn't seem like last year what we have
with wii u splatoon there's a few last
year correct so i got more you might
even spot mario maker was fantastic i
think that was like our number five game
wasn't it was up there pretty high up
and that's one of like my favorite
things in the wii u i don't know like
looking back over the entire lifespan of
the wii UI I don't want to just I'm not
hating on I enjoy the experience as I
played but I don't think I played more
than like 15 games total on the console
throughout its life span I just if I
went to it was because I absolutely had
to and I enjoyed those like I said but I
just don't feel like maybe that's why
I'm so optimistic about the switch
despite you know still questions that
are lingering I feel like I hope this is
when they turn it around right i mean
like this year was pretty good for xbox
one compared to past years and i think
maybe the scorpio kind of Lent some
optimism to that platform and everything
with that on the horizon I just I don't
know looking back I did not really value
the wii u much so holistically I think
the wii u is great but we you have some
great experiences it looking at it
year-on-year it's not that awesome but
there is not involved there is another
concept where you can play mario maker
it's that 3ds you can get a gimped
version
of mario maker on that but super mario
3d world mario kart splatoon the HD
versions of legend of zelda twilight
princess and not square treks Wind Waker
immigrant like these are great
experiences to have on the wii u and to
be able to play in your living room
earthbound like finally getting today
unload that and play that on a console
better on 3ds but like there there are a
lot of great reasons to own a Wii U but
it's definitely just kind of petered out
in this last year of its life that this
was not the waitress that's here just
kind of Justin doubt like yeah it's like
a sudden means awesome thing it totally
you know it hit it's like xbox is coming
into its Justin I think a Nintendo kind
of hit the peak of being a stubborn
company who wants to to show people how
innovative they are when no one's asking
for innovation I think they got really
lucky with with the wii i don't think i
don't think they may have known how
successful that thing would have been
and that worked out really really well
you know but the gamepad i don't
understand what they were trying to do
if they were trying to to latch on to
okay tablets are a thing touch screens
are thing they went about it in the
sloppiest way possible that's what it
was it was them saying mobile games are
really popular instead of making mobile
games let's make our own system that has
mobile interface right let's take away
why people play mobile games and just
have people try to play mobile games in
front of their TV right but yeah it was
yeah it was creating a hurdle that that
no one asked to be put up and i think
that's what's great about the switch is
that there doesn't seem to be this thing
where it's like I don't understand this
about it I understand that there is
something special it's a convertible
system but beyond that doesn't actually
impact the games that you're playing
where Nintendo had a really good habit
of getting in front of the games they
were playing with something that you
didn't really care about her asked for
and so many things didn't live up to
their full potential i mean we talked
about the hardware the tech itself but
also a huge push into the toys for life
genre with amiibo and outside of Smash
Brothers and having this huge roster of
Smash Brothers amiibo and kind of animal
crossing even though there's not much
else you can do with it like there's
just not that much amigo and very little
you can actually do with them yeah their
best is just figurines get the really
cool
nice high quality figurines that I know
I don't even like using them in games
that did record that use the mario party
i think an excellent example of a game
that used amiibo in the worst way
imaginable hasbro makes really cool
figurines as well do you call it i don't
want things from inside no just any
games i want like we got a what looks to
be one of the best Zelda's like i can't
speak to that yet we've all played like
a few hours of it but you know like
hopefully like I feel like they just
announced a new Metroid on switched like
I just want them to get back to that
stuff like this is I'm not the only
person this is nothing new and
revelatory that I'm hoping for this I
just I don't know I want them to focus
on feel like they're in the right
direction with the switch and I hope
they just now it come whenever they
release it then we didn't get this is
obviously near the last I think next
year will be the last year for the wii u
100% those switches coming out and we
went through an entire console life
cycle without experiences that
especially fans have been craving like
Metroid there was new no new Zelda for
the wii u until right now at the very
end mother 3 everybody's asking for it
never came out yeah alright well I do
want to touch on I want to kind of
rattle through some of the games this
year that we didn't mention you
mentioned twilight princess remastered
again it's a remastered re-release of
the wii of the gamecube we title it was
great i would just a launch title like
that i think that helped also catapult
sales of the week yeah Star Fox zero p
you reviewed it didn't speak too highly
of it has its moments yeah it can be
cool at times but it's doesn't play the
way I starfox game should and I I hate
to say it that way but that's kind of
the truth because they present you with
a thing that is like you remember old
Star Fox right here are very familiar
scenarios but you have to play them very
differently it's a knockout Paper Mario
color splash it's cute it's a it's
another one of those where you kind of
have that same experience that you
expect to get out of it in Nintendo
regurgitates things really well they
make these games very fun to play but
you can also only revisit that well so
many times and Mario color splash it's
it's fine it's a very serviceable mario
RPG but is that's not what people wanted
poking tournament
that's a really cool game and I feel
like the Wii U is probably the reason
it's not talked about more yeah because
I don't see if I mean I guess smash duh
but I don't really see a big fighting
game community on the Wii U and I feel
like pokin maybe shmatte well I mean
smash does have a good fighting
community behind if a pokin was like has
a very different game you know my
favorite traditional fighting game right
closer to it yeah I can spear it and i
think that was just-- may be lost on
people like it was great and then it
kind of went away and like people stop
talking about it yeah yeah i feel like
it was wasted on the way you seen
Blaziken here makes me nostalgic for
pokemon X&Y he wasn't in he wasn't in
stunning moon I haven't gotten that far
right all right anyway alright help me
out the name of this there's a hashtag
in it so take your Tokyo Mirage sessions
sharp Fe thank you I knew it was I just
wanted you to feel cool saying it I I
wanted to be the embarrassing one which
we've had I think that is also a
strength of the wii u that it has been a
champion of really great japanese based
rpgs like these experiences that fans
had had wanted for a long time Xenoblade
Chronicles or Xenoblade Chronicles X
yeah yeah an amazing game at some
problems but an amazing game that you
can really only play on the Wii U yeah
and she she Maga she's not she megami
tensei I mean it's that marriage of the
shin megami tensei series and the Fire
Emblem series and it definitely had some
issues but it was also a beautiful fun
experience in like that's that is fan
service for those people who love that
kind of game yeah so again kind of a
disappointing year for the Wii U but I
mean it's it's nearing the end of its
life and we are anticipating eagerly the
nintendo switch so we will have more
news on that in the coming months
hopefully i'm sure and you know what it
releases rising from the ashes yeah
let's hope will all burn or we use and
then they'll turn into switches yeah
we're all rooting for Nintendo let's
just hope they pull it off if you're
watching this live it's not a yet but
you can watch you can read Justin's more
in depth we you enter your report card
on gamespot if you're watching this on
youtube or the site you can't because i
didn't write it done Oh Oscar dais in
the UK will have that published as of
your viewing right now on youtube or
gamespot com
you